it just gets worse he's dying I mean
that's just the reality guys our
president the Everyman podcaster Joe
Rogan making sense for the people what
is going on with Trump's trial do you
know about that didn't they hit him with
something else he's been hit with a gag
order amazing how they're going after
him it's isn't it making him though
people rallying around more people rally
around him for sure Brian for sure no
it's it's it's definitely his loyal
followers but um
his we got the world falling apart and
then we got like Trump trying to save
the world wait a minute are you serious
yeah they're no I mean I mean that's a
possibility that's a possibility you
know it's an insane that we have a
president like Joe Biden that's you see
the picture of his chin insane he was on
the ball in Israel you got to give him
credit he went over there and smoothed
everything out it just gets worse it's
all worse for him yeah it just gets
worse he's dying I mean that's just the
reality guy our president you hear what
Joey Diaz said about him looks like he's
already got the falah hiide in
[Laughter]
him